Sí buenos días han llegado a plantear la
cantidad de cables que llegamos a
acumular a lo largo de nuestra vida Pues
bien en la Unión Europea esto pronto va
a poder tener un fin está maraña de
cabras de cables porque la el parlamento
europeo ha dado luz verde definitiva que
a partir de 2024 Máximo en un máximo de
dos años puede haber solo un solo
dispositivo un solo cargador este el
usbc que pueda ayudar a cargar todos los
dispositivos electrónicos se trata de
tabletas también de teléfonos de cámaras
de vídeo de teléfono también
videoconsolas e incluso también
auriculares o también libros
electrónicos podrán utilizar este único
dispositivo todos los fabricantes todas
las marcas sin excepción tendrán que
adecuarse a esta nueva Norma si quieren
vender sus productos dentro de la Unión
Europea qué pasa con los ordenadores
portátiles también les va a afectar pero
van a tener un poco más de tiempo en
lugar de 2024 van a tener hasta un
máximo de 4 años para poder adaptarse a
la nueva normativa para la Unión Europea
en cualquier caso se trata de un gran
éxito que otros países y otras regiones
del mundo también deberían copiar porque
tiene un verdadero una verdadera
consecuencia también para los
consumidores para el bolsillo entonces
Se podrían ahorrar 250 millones de euros
y también un impacto para el medio
ambiente se reduce este impacto porque
en la Unión Europea aproximadamente
14.000 toneladas de cables y de
cargadores acaban en la basura en toda
la Unión Europea Así que para la Unión
Europea se trata de un gran éxito que
tiene también un impacto positivo en el
medio ambiente y también para los
consumidores